um we are taking calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's talk to a few other people
at least
uh why don't we go uh to let's go to ben
from boston ben from boston you're on
the air
oh hey um
did you just call me like a minute ago i
just clicked on
the chat ben i can i can barely hear you
uh
you're gonna have to get much closer to
your microphone or something and i
i called on you now i don't know it
sounded like you were asking if i
previously called on you
i called on you now there was a
different ben i tried calling on before
but it wasn't you
thank you that makes a lot more sense
hey um
is this better it's a little better yeah
go ahead okay thank you
um so i was just wondering your take on
kind of
for going forward what what should the
mainstream media
kind of do to um kind of
quell some of this division that i see
my dad was actually
a sports journalist for many many years
in the past
and he's always told me about that a lot
of this partisanship
kind of started uh when the if you've
heard of this like um
the fairness doctrine they actually see
a fairness doctrine that
basically mandated that there had to be
uh both sides of you know both sides of
an argument to be presented there was
sort of limited number of channels
and they wanted that you know certain
channels to have you know
maybe a left leaning um perspective and
a right leaning
just have air time on on both sides and
i think reagan ended that practice
um and my dad always tells me that you
know he thinks that a lot of this kind
of
division and polarization in the news
has started around around then
um so i was just wondering um your take
on that
and and and perhaps also you know
i wondered if a lot of people don't
understand the difference between let's
say
like news and opinion yes and maybe
there should be
better um regulation i know
regulation so regulation is stuff let me
that's that's a lot so let me let me
deal with that because that's a lot of
stuff
um the people the second part is
immediate lack of media literacy
i've addressed that before we need to be
teaching media literacy
starting you know two to 11 year olds
even younger being able to identify the
difference between
content and advertising which really
young kids can't do which is why
advertising to children is so
pernicious the difference between news
and opinion that's a
we have a huge media literacy issue in
the country but the first
issue is very interesting i think at
this point there are people who say we
need a new fairness doctrine
at this point i believe that practically
speaking
because so much of the information
people are getting is on the internet
uh it seems to me that a new fairness
doctrine would be a pyrrhic victory in
the sense that you might through
huge amounts of struggle and chaos get
something done
and it would be of minimal value because
the media landscape has just changed
dramatically it's not about limited
airwaves that have to be divided fairly
in a certain way
it's a totally different situation with
people getting news from the internet so
i don't think that the regulatory
approach in terms of a new fairness
doctrine is the right approach
i think it's a we need a cultural
educational realignment
that teaches people to be
more savvy when it comes to the
information that that they consume i
feel strongly that that's the right
approach and that a new fairness
doctrine would not really be what we
need
thank you my pleasure great to hear from
you uh let's take a very quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going
right back to the phones momentarily